buonasera
sassari parlano di geni j epigenetica
ma iniziando da lontano autunno 1944 61
vanta pochi mesi prima della fine della
guerra
e già la situazione va comincio ad avere
una brutta piega per l'esercito tedesco
dopo lo sbarco in normandia gli alleati
avevano cominciato a liberare le terre
del sud dei paesi bassi
quel settembre dello stesso anno le
operazioni furono improvvisamente
interrotte il governo olandese che era
in esilio aveva chiesto ai ferrovieri
olandesi di interrompere le linee per
facilitare alcune delle strategie degli
alleati
in seguito a questa decisione
il governo tedesco ha deciso un embargo
e quindi ha interrotto tutti i trasporti
di cibo verso l'olanda i mesi successivi
sono stati dei mesi molto difficili per
la popolazione di quella terra tra
l'altro quello fu un anno
particolarmente freddo le scorte
alimentari che dovevano mediamente
durare una settimana
furono razionate in modo da poter durare
almeno un mese stime successive hanno
parlato di qualcosa come una media di
500 calorie al giorno per ogni persona
quello passò alla storia come da angelo
winter e le conseguenze sono state
drammatiche circa 20.000 persone sono
morte in quel periodo ma perchè vi parlo
di questo oggi perché quello che è stata
una pagina bruttissima la storia di un
popolo è anche passata alla storia come
un esempio classico di epigenetica
infatti le conseguenze di quel periodo
furono tantissime
studi successivi hanno dimostrato che i
bambini che sono stati concepiti durante
quel periodo hanno sviluppato durante la
loro vita tutta una serie di problemi
fisici da problemi cardiovascolari a
intolleranza al glucosio ma anche a
problemi mentali schizofrenia
depressione
e quant'altro
ma facciamo un passo indietro ora
parliamo di geni che ho parlato mi ha
accennato di genetica
parliamo di geni la creazione e lo
sviluppo di ogni individuo della nostra
specie parte sostanzialmente dallo
scambio di informazioni come pazzi sulle
informazioni che sono contenute nel
nostro codice genetico il codice
genetico di due individui della stessa
specie quando una cella sessuale materna
incrocia quella paterna
il risultato è la creazione di un nuovo
organismo nuovo che si svilupperà in
maniera del tutto nuova e che ancora
oggi non siamo in grado di prevedere di
prevedere in seguito a questo scambio di
informazioni siano una serie di fasi
dello sviluppo
quelle che vedete qui sono fasi dello
sviluppo embrionale che tutti conosciamo
ma anche dopo la nascita ci sono molte
fasi dello sviluppo individuo che durano
tutta la vita è molto interessante il
fatto che gli individui della nostra
specie
al momento della nascita sono inviti
molto immaturi
infatti abbiamo bisogno delle cure
parentali per poter sopravvivere e parlo
di meccanismi di base come
appunto riscaldarsi nutrirsi a
meccanismi molto più complessi che
coinvolgono apprendimento e sviluppo di
personalità eccetera eccetera
la sensazione però che abbiamo davanti a
questa genetica è una sensazione un po
strana
a volte abbiamo la sensazione che si
hanno degli spettatori un po psi v
se nel senso che subito dopo lo scambio
di questa informazione genetica alla
fine dobbiamo fare solo un copia incolla
dei nostri geni e il resto va da sé lo
sviluppo del feto lo sviluppo del
bambino sono tutti che ci sembra una
sensazione dei programmi prestabiliti
sui quali non possiamo intervenire
inoltre c'è anche una ci sono a volte
opportunistica della genetica quando le
cose vanno bene
chiaramente è tutto merito dei geni no
come in questo caso se mio figlio è un
genio della matematica è tutto suo padre
se le cose invece sono difficili deve
essere poco salto oppure tutto sonore
questa è una visione un po
opportunistica e chiaramente dalle di
genetica della genetica ma anche in un
certo senso delle radici nella
letteratura scientifica per anni ci
siamo concentrati nel cercare di
identificare delle sequenze dei nostri
geni che siano inoltre modo associate ha
dei tratti ben precisi tratti fisici
tratti psicologici eccetera eccetera
in seguito alla lettura estesa del
nostro genoma del genoma di molti altri
in di molte altre specie quello che è
successo che ci siamo ritrovati con
lunghissima sequenza di lettere per le
pari tra l'altro siamo stati molto bravi
a capire come sono organizzati come
utilizzare questa informazione anche uno
modificarle
ma ancora oggi abbiamo pochissimo
conoscenza delle loro funzioni
l'approccio in questo campo scientifico
è stato quello di una vera e propria
colonizzazione dei territori
cioè scienziati di tutto il mondo di
tutte le varie discipline
inizia si sono lanciati in una certa una
specie di corsa
contro il tempo per cercare di mettere
una bandierina su ogni genere e quindi
nel mio campo della neuro genetica sono
stati gli studi che hanno dimostrato che
ci sono dei geni per l'aggressività
gente la paura generata dei geni per le
emozioni della serata c'è stato il
momento delle patologie e quindi gen
lance ogni genere per l'autismo per la
schizofrenia e così via dicendo
il tentativo è stato quello di creare
una mappa completa di tutte le funzioni
del nostro genoma
ma le cose sono rivelate un po più
complicate di questo in alcuni casi è
stato possibile rintracciare delle
funzioni specifiche per dei geni in
altri casi è stato molto più difficile è
ora vi riassumo due motivi sostanziali
per questo problema senza usare grandi
paroloni il concetto di base di cui
voglio parlarvi è un riassunto nel
famoso motto di rimas tutti per uno uno
per tutti è infatti quello che sappiamo
che ogni genere è capace di influenzare
diversi tratti del nostro organismo e
diversi geni hanno un contributo su uno
stesso tratto moltissimi più di due
davvero tanti
faccio un esempio l'altezza che in un
tratto molto studiato in ambito genetico
in uno studio recente si è visto che
migliaia e migliaia di sequenze sparse
lungo il nostro genoma sono capaci di
influenzare l'altezza ognuna di queste
con un effetto molto piccolo ma che
comunque è significativamente superiore
a 0
ok un altro tipo di meccanismi molto
importanti sono stati quelli epigenetici
cioè tutti quei processi cellulari che
influenzano l'espressione o meno di cene
senza modificarne la sequenza del dna
e questi sono molto importanti vedremo
anche perchè allora siamo vicino a
natale per farvi capire esattamente cosa
che tipo di informazione ci dà un gene
mi sono inventato questo esempio
cerchiamo di aiutare qualcuno che in
questo momento sarà molto occupato
qualcuno che tra qualche giorno
dovrà distribuire milioni e milioni di
regali in tutto il mondo in una sola
notte
sappiamo di chi stiamo parlando come
fare aiutarlo
ecco vi propongo di fare uno screening
genetico per babbo natale e allora mi
sono inventato un genere
e qui la mia credibilità scientifica
adesso sia completamente rovinata noi
siamo il geni chrismas i geni christmas
a due varianti la variante dei noti
chris noti è la variante di quelli buoni
chris nice e noi andiamo a vedere la
popolazione troviamo due distribuzioni
due curve a campana come queste
come vedete c'è una sovrapposizione tra
le due campane le cose in queste due
curve si sovrappongono noi potremmo
essere molto fortunati e avere una
situazione come questa in cui la
sovrapposizione delle due curve e
piccolissima in questo caso di
informazione genetica che abbiamo il
genotipo dell'individuo e informativo
predice se un individuo sarà buono o
cattivo potremmo però trovarci anche
un'altra situazione nella situazione
come questa in cui c'è una grossa
sovrapposizione tra le due curve e in
quel caso l'informazione genetico il
nostro genotipo non aiuta a babbo natale
a selezionare i buoni e cattivi
ecco questo è un esempio di fantasia ma
nella realtà le cose non sono andate
tanto diverso da quello che vi ho appena
presentato infatti alcuni anni fa
abbiamo cercato di mettere insieme tutti
gli studi genetici disposizione fino a
quel momento per cercare di capire che
tipo di contributo da ogni genere o
diversi geni su un tratto o su una
patologia
ecco il risultato di questo studio è
stato un po sconfortante perché
l'informazione genetica può spiegare
qualcosa come il 5 e il 10 per cento
della variabilità nella popolazione che
fine ha fatto il resto del 90 per cento
ecco quel 90 per cento è dovuto a
meccanismi epigenetici
avevo parlato alle interazioni tra i
geni ha fatto che alcune sequenze di ge
ricadono in zone del nostro genoma che
ancora non abbiamo studiato a fondo è
anche importante l'interazione tra i
geni nell'ambiente e l'interazione tra
generalmente è esempi per questo sono
tantissimi
prima avevo parlato di la fame in olanda
o di tempo non è stato un'icona di
bellezza per la cinematografia di molti
anni eccole ha vissuto l'esperienza
della hangar winter e per tutta la sua
vita ha sofferto di molti disturbi
fisici disturbi della respirazione
anemia una fortissima depressione e si è
spenta in età molto giovane per via di
un cancro
altro esempio lo studio di recente ha
dimostrato che donne che erano nella
terza nella fase finale di gravidanza
durante l'attacco alle torri gemelle e
ha sviluppato disturbo post traumatico
da stress è un anno dopo anche i loro
bambini avremo alti i livelli di
cortisolo
questi sono alcuni degli esempi di avere
genetica
ecco ritrovati voglio parlare di un
qualcosa che sappiamo fare e in realtà
viste movimento un paradosso scientifico
e il paradosso così è rappresentato dal
fatto che sappiamo fare più di quello
che capiamo
sembra assurdo ma è così
negli anni abbiamo affinato tutte le
tecniche possibili e immaginabili per
modificare i nostri geni
tutto questo rientra in una categoria
per quello del gene editing
ed è proprio nel proprio l'editing così
come facciano l'editing manoscritto in
laboratorio siamo in grado di fare un
editing dei nostri geni
negli ultimi anni queste tecniche sono
diventate ancora più raffinate siamo
molto più veloci qualche settimana fa
tutti abbiamo seguito l'elenco delle
notizie che venivano dalla cina
un medico cinese è stato ha modificato
il genoma di alcune bambine
la cosa chiaramente ha suscitato da
tantissimi rapito discussione
e su questioni etiche né morali ecco dal
mio punto di vista prima di arrivare
alle questioni etiche e in questa è una
pressione tecnica e non inserisco al
fatto che ancora la tecnica non è
preciso al cento per cento ma riferisco
al fatto di quello che ho raccontato
stasera che la nostra conoscenza delle
funzioni di questi geni è ancora
limitata quindi non sappiamo quel medico
cinese che in realtà cosa modificato nel
genoma di queste due bambine
allora spero per concludere gli anelli
dimostrato che il codice genetico che
abbiamo un codice molto importante per
la vita
sulla terra ma è un codice che non ha
dei programmi rigidi questi programmi
possono essere modificati possono essere
influenzati era importante il modo in
cui l'influenza mo quindi quello che
dobbiamo fare e migliorare le condizioni
di vita sulla terra
faccio un esempio traumi abusi qualunque
tipo di esperienza negativa in tutte le
fasi dello sviluppo dal fase embrionale
ha subito la nascita hanno delle
conseguenze drammatiche per la salute
dell'individuo a uno studio di recente
ha dimostrato che il 20 per cento degli
individui che hanno subito traumi abusi
hanno vissuto in gravi star di povertà
durante l'infanzia possono pesare per
l'ottanta per cento della spesa pubblica
sanitaria
ecco quindi la questione non è solo un
problema per individuo è un problema per
l'economia della società e di questo
dobbiamo prenderci carico e noi con gli
scienziati
dobbiamo continuare la ricerca di base
perché è molto importante
e qui mi ricordava anche il work in
progress
dobbiamo capire le funzioni di questi
geni prima ancora di andare a modificare
grazie
[Applauso]